the national rifle association has been
one of the most powerful
if not the most powerful lobbying groups
in america
the nra is very powerful not just
because it has a lot of money but
because it has
a lot of sway with single-issue pro-gun
voters
it says that it has about five million
members
committed to gun ownership and the
second amendment
we're all just wanting to exercise our
second amendment rights to protect
ourselves
protect our property i love the nra
i love the second amendment they've
mobilized the single issue voter on this
topic
up and down the entire ballot and
they've successfully done that for years
there's a shooting there's a shooting
gun violence in america
yes we need more guns
[Music]
but at the peak of its power the nra
finds itself
besieged by scandals and legal
challenges that threaten
its very existence executives of the nra
are accused of looting the powerful gun
rights groups to the tune of millions of
dollars gun owners across america should
be horrified by what i saw inside the
nra
an unchecked corporation with too much
power
it's fighting against attorneys general
in new york
in washington dc it's fighting a legal
battle against its former
advertising agency it's spending
millions and millions of dollars on
legal bills
there was a vicious civil war between
wayne lapierre and oliver north and it
was very dramatic
and very expensive it has had
large-scale layoffs
and it does seem that the nra is having
a lot of trouble
while trouble does not necessarily mean
their ultimate demise
there is no doubt that in recent years
the nra
shot itself in the foot
[Music]
the nra wasn't always all powerful or
even political for that matter
the nra was formed in 1871 by two former
union soldiers
many people in the north just didn't
know how to use guns and so the nra's
mission was to train people how to use
guns
in the event there's another war it
remained a non-controversial gun safety
organization for over a hundred years
its earliest foray into politics can be
traced back to the national firearms act
in 1934
this major piece of gun control
legislation was actually supported by
the nra
something the nra of today would
consider heresy
it would take another five decades for
the humble non-profit to transform into
a pro-gun lobby group
and ardent opponent of gun regulations
it is today
the nra became a little more political
starting in the 1970s and really ramped
up its political efforts throughout the
80s and 90s
pushing back on any efforts by states or
congress to
restrict gun rights through background
checks or waiting periods before guns
could be purchased
from my cold dead hands
the nra raises its money from membership
fees and donations from wealthy
individuals and gun manufacturers
but it isn't just one simple non-profit
organization anymore
along with its political transformation
came a multitude of offshoot foundations
for varying purposes what we call the
nra is really a number of different
organizations
it has a political spending arm and it
has a charitable foundation
the organizations have to keep separate
books but they don't have to operate
fully independently of one another and
indeed
they're all basically run by wayne
lapierre the head of the nra
[Music]
wayne lapierre is basically a walking
talking
iteration of the national rifle
association he's not
an avid shooter himself but nonetheless
he's been a very effective lobbyist
for gun rights and been a very effective
spokesperson
for the nra we're never going to stop
fighting for your right
and folks just like you all over america
to have the right to defend themselves
what's the location of the emergency
school i think there's somebody
shooting in here lapierre became
somewhat of a household
name in 2012 when he offered a defensive
and seemingly tone-deaf response
to the school massacre at sandy hook the
only thing
that stops a bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun
the nra does best when it's under attack
during the obama administration you had
a spate of tragic
mass killings in the united states and
this put the gun world on the defensive
[Music]
when people feel that their access or
their ability
to obtain and keep guns is threatened
that's when they support the national
rifle association
and indeed it was boom time for both nra
membership enrollment
and gun sales in america under the
leadership of la pierre
the nra was credited for defeating
president obama's legislative agenda
for stronger gun regulations in his
second term
all in all this was a pretty shameful
day for washington
and of course the nra was an early
backer of the trump campaign
[Applause]
the second amendment is so important
they're not going to take your guns away
folks they're not going to take you
against it
the nra went to great pains to get
donald trump elected
i'm officially announcing the nra's
endorsement of donald trump for
president
and they were able to amass
very large sums of money for donald
trump 30 million dollars
and about 54 million dollars for the
entire election
and they were very successful the
election of donald trump in november
2016
seemed to signal that the nra was at the
peak of its
power high on its own success
the nra ventured to launch nratv
an ambitious online media network
dedicated not only to gun culture
but to the culture wars in general satan
hates everything good about america
so does capri men were made to create
they were made to
conquer much of nratv
was filled with right-wing screeds
against immigration
against journalists against fake news
against liberals
not all muslims are radicalized but all
radicalized terrorists
are muslims but nratv turned out to be a
resounding failure
i never would have imagined these little
neat pockets and hidden closures
not that many people were watching it
and it was very expensive for the nra to
produce
the answer to the question what the nra
tv
is it's just a vessel to sell america
guns
that's pretty much it nratv was a bad
business decision for the nra it cost
the nra something like 40 million
dollars and got very very few viewers
the failure of nra tv eventually came
back to haunt them
and ultimately led to the first real
signs of trouble for the foundation
i see it it was the white hoods and the
burning train tracks okay
fine fair point now i should warn you
this is where things get
complicated
the nra's troubles really began in
october of 2017
when new york state launched an
investigation into an insurance product
called
carryguard and it turned out the nra
didn't have the right permits under new
york insurance law to be selling this
insurance
and that caused the nra to hire a new
lawyer a fellow by the name of william
brewer
he warned that the nra was likely to be
further investigated by the state of new
york
brewers suggested that the nra conduct a
full-scale internal audit to ensure
their books were in order
a large part of which involved tracking
the enormous expenditures
incurred by their long-time pr agency
ackerman
mcqueen among other pr services rendered
during their decades-long relationship
ackerman mcqueen billed 40 million
dollars for the nra tv
project this included a large
undisclosed salary
to then nra president oliver north
theoretically an unpaid position
for his appearances on nra tv i spent my
life with those who who
relish a good fair fight he was making a
salary of
apparently over a million dollars a year
and the nra
said we we need to review that contract
but it's really only the tip of the
iceberg it turns out that
the nra and ackermann mcqueen had
profound disagreements
ackermann mcqueen responded by detailing
to the public
that wayne lapierre and other people who
were at the head of the nra
were taking advantage of the nra's
charitable status
using it for personal expenses such as
expensive travel to the bahamas
shopping trips in beverly hills where
wayne lapierre would spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and it even came out that wayne lapierre
had a secret 17 million dollar golden
parachute contract
[Music]
oliver north had been pressing the nra's
board to investigate the nra's
expenditures including with ackerman
mcqueen and even
the nra's law firm in april of 2019 the
nra filed a lawsuit against akrom
mcqueen
for overbilling and lack of transparency
just days before the new yorker
dropped a bombshell report alleging
corruption on a staggering scale
with a particular focus on the
questionable relationship
between ackermann mcqueen and the nra so
the new york attorney general alleges
that the nra was using ackermann
mcqueen's expenses
to enrich its leadership through
improper spending
the new yorker article quoted a former
irs official in charge of overseeing
tax-exempt organizations as saying that
the nra
had a litany of red flags that were
quote just
extraordinary ackerman mcqueen and
oliver north have not responded to
requests for comment
and in court filings ackermann mcqueen
has denied the nra allegations
all this acrimony made for a tense
annual nra meeting
the following week oliver north
threatened
wayne lapierre said he would disclose
information about his incredible
spending with the nra's money on
personal expenses
if wayne lapierre didn't step down from
leadership of the organization
lapierre quickly retaliated and accused
north and ackermann mcqueen of trying to
carry out a coup
oliver north brought his issue to the
board but when the board meeting ended
wayne lapierre was still there and
oliver north was out as president
and indeed in the months to come wayne
lapierre
would purge virtually all of the
ackermann mcqueen's supporters
including chris cox the head of the
nra's legislative
arm and lobbying arm and before long
lapierre was standing alone
[Music]
but for lapierre it was a pyrrhic
victory
so the internal fight was over but it
had the effect of triggering what became
the new york attorney general's lawsuit
against the nra
enter leticia james the new sheriff in
town
so leticia james is a democrat and she
was elected back in 2018 to become new
york's top law enforcement officer
james ran on a platform of challenging
donald trump
but she was also highly critical of the
nra which she accused of being a
terrorist organization
a claim that the nra claims is
defamatory and false
but it was the revelations that came out
of the ackermann mcqueen lawsuit
that really provided her a basis to go
after the nra
so attorney general james rolled up her
sleeves and dug in
obtaining sworn testimony from key
players including oliver north
and reviewing thousands of pages of
documents many of which the nra
attempted to withhold from her
especially when it came to any
information pertaining to their
relationship with ackermann mcqueen
but eventually james had seen enough
it's clear that the nra has been failing
to carry out its stated mission for many
many years
and instead has operated as a breeding
ground
for greed abuse
and brazen illegality the nra has denied
new york's allegations
calling the lawsuit a baseless political
attack on the organization
around the same time that new york filed
its lawsuit the district of columbia
attorney general carl racine
also a democrat filed a separate lawsuit
against the nra and the nra foundation
accusing the foundation of allowing
charitable funds to be
used for improper purposes on october 19
2020 the nra filed a response to the new
york attorney
general's lawsuit asking to have the
case dismissed
calling it the capstone of a partisan
election interference project
it's anyone's guess when the judge will
respond to the nra's request and this
really is just the beginning of the case
what we do know is that the nra has been
hemorrhaging money
on fees to combat ongoing legal battles
on every
imaginable front part of the nra's
financial
situation comes from incredible legal
fees
william brewer and his law firm have
been charging the nra
more than 1.3 million dollars a month
a filing by ackermann claims that
brewer's law firm has collected
54 million dollars in the two years of
representing the nra
in a leaked audio recording la pierre
told surviving board members that the
nra
is in serious financial trouble the cost
that we wore was probably about 100
million
[Music]
that was back in january 2020 before the
filings in new york state and dc
not to mention the layoffs it's had to
do after the coronavirus outbreak
so they can only expect to keep spending
a lot more
to add insult to injury recently ousted
joshua powell has released a tell-all
book
with first-hand accounts of alleged
misconduct across the board
it is an abomination of members money
that what's gone on over the past 30
years it's to the tune of hundreds of
millions of dollars in wastage
the allegations make you seem like part
of the problem though
i understand that he's blaming uh his
own misdeeds in many ways
as just part of the culture of the nra
and indeed it does appear increasingly
likely that there was a culture of the
nra where leadership
basically treated the organization like
personal piggy bank
the nra rejected powell's allegations so
right now the nra is in full
defense mode this means that millions of
dollars that the nra would normally
spend on
lobbying and donations is being spent
instead on law firms and legal fees
just at a time when they're fighting for
their survival
there's no ending to this story yet and
it's far too soon for the nra's enemies
to do a victory lap
lapierre is working hard to paint
himself and the organization
as the victim of vicious partisan
attacks they think they're getting our
guns
i'm just telling them 1776 is going to
kick off again
the nra is using these existential
threats to gin up support and raise the
money needed to dig itself out of dire
straits
beat all the cases against it and come
out stronger than ever
although the attorney general has sought
to dissolve the nra that does seem like
an
unlikely ultimate outcome from this i
think it is very possible that the nra
will be hit with significant fines be
and be forced to remove certain members
of the board like wayne lapierre
regardless of the outcome there's a
universal lesson to be learned here
as old as time itself the nra's downfall
seems likely to come from its own hubris
one of the dangers of being the most
powerful political organization in
america
is you feel that no one can beat you but
new york attorney general leticia james
has got something to say about that
you